We're asked to multiply
65 times 1.
So literally, we just need to
multiply 65-- we could write
it is a times sign like that or
we could write it as a dot
like that-- but this
means 65 times 1.
And there's two ways
to interpret this.
You could view this as the
number 65 one time or you
could view this as the
number 1 sixty-five
times, all added up.
But either way, if you have one
65, this is literally just
going to be 65.
Anything times 1 is going
to be that anything,
whatever this is.
Whatever this is times
1 is going to be
that same thing again.
If I have just some kind of
placeholder here times 1, and
I could even write it as the
times symbol times 1, that's
going to be that same
placeholder.
So if I have 3 times 1,
I'm going to get 3.
If I have 5 times 1, I'm going
to get 5, because literally,
all this is saying
is 5 one time.
If I put-- I don't know-- 157
times 1, that'll be 157.
I think you get the idea.